hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to let's play illusion once
again another indie horror game that I
would like to give a try this one
obviously you guys have been doing a
great job in giving me suggestions keep
them coming even if you think I may have
heard of it before it doesn't matter
because I don't get angry if you're like
come out with something I've already
heard of it I'm gonna play just give me
whatever you can so that it don't
overlook anything
hi so here we go
collect eight papers and escape to car
oh is this a slender Tim is this a
slender game I have a cop car am i a cop
can I have that please good I enjoyed oh
god do that right uh uh there we go okay
picked it up with the left mouse button
oh please don't tell me this is slender
game uh-huh
okay this was made in the Unity engine
ah
it's oh is that jump scared galore
I have a feeling about this game hi hi
hi hi hi hi what the I'm not looking at
him no can't look at that guy apparently
not even through a door what that what
the boy hey whoa oh oh oh okay I
remember that that was a halflife noise
that was one of the citizens from
half-life oh that is a creepy Victor oh
I know what the thumbnails got a baby oh
good god okay well let's try that again
I don't know I wasn't trying to look at
the guy but it just so happened okay I
don't think there was anything in there
besides jump scares so I'm gonna go up
here now herbert erpaderp hurt for derpy
who's gonna jump out of me
ah
whoa chair what the hell chair you okay
out there what the hell is going on in
this house why my I haven't seen a
single page let alone eight let me know
how I collect them
left click I guess everything's the same
wood you made the entire house out of
one man I can't go upstairs here okay is
it oh god I can't I can't do anything
the heart beating is getting faster yeah
will you what dad
Oh what Dad I don't know your face
yep jump-scares galore I had a feeling
come on you gotta do better than that
man you gotta do better than this
creator of the game there's got to be
more substance than just jump scares
okay I'm better now my heart has stopped
beating maybe I'm gonna go out of the
house now that pot good idea let me
check around the house in the woods
maybe I only saw the one page I mean it
was all brown on brown so it would have
been very easy to lose it oh wait no
there seems to be a lot of wood out here
Woods aha Oh it says oh it's that page
after page it's he run from Mom's house
where I'm banging her oh oh what the
hell
I think this is like a slender imitation
of sorts mmm God you better than direct
copying the same material I mean I don't
I'm not faulting anyone for trying to
make a game they're doing better than I
can
given that I have never made a game and
people who out there criticize should
remember you've never made a game either
or most of you MA some of you have but
anyone who has made a game can criticize
sin call this for what it is so
see here huh there's those two pages
right one after another and now I'm just
walking in the same direction towards a
mountain range I can hit an invisible
wall here unless the guy didn't set up
an invisible wall and I'm just gonna
walk forever I am I am going to walk
forever till I hit the mountain oh hello
all right here's the mountain there's
the moon going up the mountain I'm
pretty sure this isn't supposed to be
happening in the game I can walk
straight up not cannot okay so going
back ah why does it Oh digit hey guy
here Oh
interesting interesting
hmm hmm I've got plenty of battery and
I've been wandering for quite a while
mm-hmm I mean I got no clues as to where
these pages may be there's no landmarks
there's no anything it's just all the
same woods it's all the same grass
texture it's pretty it's pretty you know
well it does say development bill so
it's a pretty early stage of the game so
I guess I won't criticize it too much
yeah but you guys can see how quickly
the jump scares kind of fade after a
while I mean they go from you know scary
the atmosphere was good in the beginning
I will agree but they go from scary to
just surprising and surprising isn't
scary I hear a heartbeat wait a minute I
can I walk towards the heartbeat no it's
ah [ __ ] you yeah you see I mean it's
just surprising loud noises are always
surprising gonna make it flinch no
matter what now the heart beats just in
my left ear I kept turning I thought I
heard it but it was just in my left ear
mm-hmm
where's these pages I'm gonna run out of
battery before I find anything the
health regenerates actually it's like
it's kind of like the Slender static
which
where you face it and it's staticky and
it fades away after a while I'm not even
sure what the monster is it looks just
like a normal person there's nothing
strange about him gone back at the
housei I guess that's a good thing I was
getting lost I'm assuming that the pages
must be nearby the house it can't be
that far out maybe he's stuck a page on
the ass end of my cop car here I have a
cop where's my freaking gun at this
point I would be authorized to use
lethal force oh why can't I just get out
of here anyway what's keeping me here
what the I would kill you not if I kill
you first uh I got here I'm not even
looking at you ever see see what I mean
see what I mean after a while jump
scares are just eight and now he's doing
why are you still there buddy
I can't I'm looking at you hmm there's
no pages in here about what am i do what
am i do I'm just gonna run past Oh see
huh you're kind of freaky but I mean
there's nothing special about you as far
as I know are you backed up by some war
or something oh yeah I lost creeps
victory go oh oh all right so um I'm
gonna I'm gonna cut it here because I
don't know I gave it a good try
it's obviously a very early build so I
can't I can't like fault it for trying
but it's almost an exact copy of slender
except that it's not slender's the main
enemy so I don't know what to make of
this you guys tell me what you think of
his game in the comments below remember
great fairly for the game itself if you
go to the game play it for yourself just
take it for what it is it's a early game
a guy is just trying to make a game so
be very mindful of that when you're
giving your reviews um let me know what
you think of the game in the comments
below there in the comments below you
can say whatever you want just say
whatever you want about it so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you
were in the next video bye-bye
ah to the trash